welcome back to chris news next we're
taking the advice column and giving it
that drew's news spin this is
ask a desk
you got it you got it
you said it um as we like to say here
we're not experts all right we are desk
spurts which is harder to say try it at
home desperate so yeah so if you're in a
pickle we'd love to try to help and
today we're taking all our questions
from social media all right fun our
first question comes from jennifer
levine on twitter jennifer writes my
friend keeps trying to set me up with
her good guy friend but i'm not
attracted to him should i give him a
chance or be honest and turn it down
thoughts rossie well you know i like to
believe because i've watched so many
romantic comedies that sometimes you
know you have to get to know somebody so
you should give them a chance now that
being said if he's a total groto i can't
help right
okay by the way did you hear when gail
king came on here she's like i don't
want a booga bear yeah she did she was
here i said you got to go you got to
give people a chance and she said book a
bear i don't want a booga bear i was
like that's my new favorite term ever
but but i don't you truly believe that
you can fall in so in love with somebody
if you get to know them
yes
yes
okay there's tom green
so yeah like
and i mean that like
you know
it's like i got to know his talent i
fell madly in love with him and
you know he was
like some people thought he was like a
gross out comedian some people thought
he was like revelatory and a pioneer
because he was yes he was um
and yeah i think someone's like
personality and talent and intelligence
and wit
and heart
like looks fade who's going to be like
an amazing person funny kind good that's
what i'm looking for yeah
i'm sorry it was a quote from you called
drag race um look spade dumbest forever
looks faith dumbest forever yes thank
you yeah the rupaul's drag race does
teach the children doesn't it thank you
so much oh you know it's olive's
favorite show i do know this um yeah so
i would say
um
why not you know
why not why not go on the date because
the least like the worst thing that's
going to happen to you is you're going
to get dinner a cocktail and a great
story right
or you might sleep together it might get
super awkward and then you're gonna have
to figure it out from there but you're
grown up so i'm sure you can
what drew barrymore said yeah go for it
go for it all right we have another
question this comes from linda bernstein
on facebook linda writes my daughter
keeps talking about the dark lipstick
trend on tick tock we had beauty week we
talked about it yeah she said i'm 61 and
i'm not sure i can wear a black lip are
there other options so drew you're going
to take the lead on this one because
with flower beauty you know you're the
you're the expert desperate
let's see here okay
black lipstick is intense but if you
want to play
in sort of the dark lip trend
dark purple is a really great thing to
play with because it actually in certain
lights can look almost
dark as black but because of the purple
in it it's going to be very flattering
to skin tone let's see drew do it okay
put this okay so this is the flower
beauty
so i'm just going to put this on a
little hard to talk while i'm dying yet
i can do it okay you'll notice drew's
putting on a purple lipstick exactly
lining the outside filling the inside
these are my favorite these are scribble
sticks and you can put them
all over your face there you go
just
really that looks great
[Applause]
this is a fun way to like
and you know you could just try
something new and different oh my gosh a
side part and a dark lip
yourself
and finally from caitlyn jackson on
instagram for any party i always bring
my special mashed potatoes and my
mother-in-law loves them but keeps
asking me for the secret recipe
turns out they are boston markets
do i tell her the truth
ross
kaitlyn take it to your grave honey take
it
to your great
the only thing i will say in
contradiction to that rossi is i went to
this restaurant and i was so obsessed
with their cheesecake and it came in
little individual tins so i kept saying
like how do you make it can i get the
recipe like did you get it somewhere and
they wouldn't they just kept looking at
me really weird and i was like i really
i can't live without this cheesecake and
finally they came back and they're like
it's sam's club and i was like thank you
and i went and bought it and i've ate it
ever since and it's my favorite
cheesecake so
i say just go for it and tell her yeah
don't listen to drew barrymore
[Laughter]
i mean maybe she wants those mashed
potatoes
more i know but this is the one power
she has over her mother-in-law keep it
keep it katelyn
oh you're right
um
and if you have a conundrum and you
would like us to help please write to us
because we would love to get involved
yeah you're welcome everyone you're
welcome we'll be right back
[Music]